augmented reality helps people
experience digital information in a new
way
join us as we talk to torch about how
they're enabling anyone to build a our
experiences on this episode of snapchat
thanks for joining us Josh tell us a
little bit more about what torch does
thanks for having me mark torch is an AR
design and publishing platform so we
we're a mobile first workflow for
building AR inside of a are we let
designers very quickly prototype and
develop augmented reality experiences
that they can then share with other
people so what does the architecture
look like for people who are going to go
in and then build an AR app so we had
three main goals when building torch one
auto we wanted the camera first mobile
first workflow we wanted to allow people
to easily bring in whatever assets they
have whether it's images video 3d models
all that and then we wanted to enable
collaboration and sort of semi real-time
collaboration between users on the
platform so we went with firebase for
the mobile device portion of that
because it allowed us to not really pay
attention to a lot of what we needed to
do to offload computation into the cloud
you know working on a mobile device
we're already very limited with CPU and
GPU we're running computer vision to do
AR we're running real-time 3d rendering
at 60 frames a second so we needed to be
able to shift some of that computation
in the end of the cloud and firebase
lets us do that really easily by calling
cloud functions by using real-time
databases things like that for asset
import we wanted to be able to support
all sorts of file types and to do it in
a very fast and efficient manner and so
we did that through a combination of
firebase functions and gke so rather
than trying to do any kind of
computational expensive processing on
the mobile device we ship assets to the
cloud run them through a cloud processor
in JK and then ship them back into
functions where we then an update fire
store and that lets the mobile device
know that every
everything is ready some examples of
what we do in the cloud are encoding
images into GPU formats we do model
conversions between various 3d file
formats we process video for real time
things like that and then for
collaboration we are really leaning
heavily on the firestore so we use
real-time snapshotting in order to let
multiple clients be writing to the same
set of documents and in real time update
everything that's happening as as it's
happening we do this a little bit
differently than you might think so
we're not using single documents as a
document store we're doing time series
data and what's also known as events or
saying where every event has ever
happened in a project we know and we
track and then to build up the final
result you run through every event and
generate the full scene document the
full project document and then for
performance and bandwidth reasons every
once in a while in a cloud function we
will what we call checkpoint those
events and so that takes those events
that up until a certain time turns it
into the final project format and so
then to retrieve a project we retrieve
the latest checkpoint and any event that
has happened since so it sounds like a
lot of the real-time collaboration of
course depends on fire store what made
you choose fire store is the right way
to handle this so we had two main
reasons for that because we're primarily
a mobile app and we didn't want to write
any cloud infrastructure that we didn't
really need to direct access to the DB
from mobile and from cloud functions was
it was really important to us on the
other side of that that's a really
double-edged sword because it means that
you need to be really careful about your
schema management and and making sure
that you're not doing anything bad on
either side of those and so what we
ended up doing is building a type safe
layer in typescript for access to the
database that makes sure that you know
programmers are not willy-nilly
schema changing things when we don't
know about it and then we've also added
the ability to version a document and
migrate between between versions so the
second reason we chose firestore is due
to that snapshotting that i talked about
earlier where we can just set up
callbacks and get live data as things
change and it's just really easy to hook
into I took into application state and
so it just it provides us with a
programming model that makes all that
early easy so it sounds like you may
have made some changes over time if you
could go back and re architect this
based on what you learned over the
process what would you do differently so
the first thing is if we would redo it
today cabrón now exists and so a lot of
what we actually built up in gke to the
you asset processing we could do without
having to build what we built in GTA and
so we would probably move as much of our
as much of the code that is in gke and
Cod functions into cabrón
but it didn't exist at the time so oh
well
the second thing is schema management
the schema that we first chose for
assets made it very expensive for us to
determine does a user have access to
this asset and so what we've ended up
with is in order to securely store
assets but also make it very cheap for
users for clients to access any
information they need to download an
asset
we we do real-time syncing of asset data
into the project so any any information
that a client needs in order to recreate
the project gets mirrored into the
project thanks for telling us about how
you actually built this application to
help other people build their own
applications absolutely thanks for
having me
get started with cloud firestore by
checking out this Quick Start Guide
thanks for watching and make sure to
subscribe for more great Google cloud
platform content we'll see you next time
on stack check